the global elite gather once a year in a
small town nestled in the Swiss Alps to
discuss political economic and
humanitarian challenges facing the world
as a businessman Trump actually never
made the guest list and he's the first
president to go to Davos since Bill
Clinton who only attended his last year
in office well it's a conference where
your net worth is described with B's not
M's yes as in billions and where people
with Trump's populist views are
considered persona non grata a world
leaders from business to politics issued
a series of dire warnings in advance of
Trump's appearance at Davos and I'll bet
they's made the editorial writers at the
Wall Street Journal giddy now he's going
to Davos and this is really boil
meeting water from my perspective I feel
like he's going to get a bad reception
there this year the protesters seem
particularly inspired Trump takes the
fun out of fondue that's just a bad
poster what do I mean they're really
stretching
well once again Trump has defied
expectations and it's surprise in the
world the president crashed their swanky
globalist party today and though the
world leaders continue to hit his
policies on trade as protectionist
they're taking notice
elites scrambled to take selfies with
him and they couldn't stop talking about
and they're elbowing each other out of
the way along that that stairway or
escalator to get close and there was
substance from the president as well it
wasn't just the one at the photo they
wanted to hear what he had to say and
sitting next to Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu Trump threatened to
withhold aid to the Palestinians unless
they returned to peace talks and then
this is important he challenged
Netanyahu Israel doesn't want to make
this and they're gonna have to want to
make peace too
or we're gonna have nothing to do with
it any longer they never got past
Jerusalem we took it off the table we
don't have to talk about it anymore
you won one point and you'll give up
some points later on the negotiation if
it ever takes place I don't know that it
ever will take place
yeah baby had to grab the petrol for
that mom I was like wait a second I
don't think we talked about that I think
that's a gutsy negotiator working for a
deal in real time you see it all play
out then the president sat down with UK
prime minister Theresa May who's still
suffering from the post brexit blues and
it is been reported that she has had a
very strained relationship with
President Trump well at the conclusion
of the meeting it was announced that the
president's trip to the UK is back on
track it will happen within the year
well it's gonna be a working trip state
visit we don't know but it's a win
nonetheless a contrary to all that
hyperbole coming from the we are the
world types Trump isn't going to stop
trading with other countries he's not
itching to blow up the world and he's
not going to stop all immigration into
the u.s. in fact we have a lot of news
later on on the show about what will be
specifically offered in the president's
deal on immigration but what President
Trump will do is he'll pursue changes in
policies that have been detrimental to
us workers US manufacturing and
importantly us wages now what does that
mean that means that America will no
longer tolerate being a taken advantage
of by freeloaders or cheated in
international trade deals or have its
intellectual property stolen by rivals
those days are over and whether you're
an ally like South Korea or an adversary
like China our president has put you on
notice that the old days of practicing
globalization on the backs of the
American people are also over my
administration is taking power back
from global bureaucrats and returning
that power back to the American people
and you see it all the time you see it
economically you see it at the church
you see it in every different way we
don't sing a global anthem we sing the
American anthem he's not president of
the world he's president of the United
States
and though some of these world leaders
continue to you know deride his policies
even chide him for the sidelines they're
taking notice and if you listen closely
it's hard to miss how trumpism the
pragmatic approach to issues like
asylees and refugees and immigration is
maybe transforming the way other leaders
think about these issues this is German
Chancellor Angela Merkel from today
reached out you in its foreign policy
has not been all that active we need to
take more responsibility we need to take
our destiny into our own hands we agree
Angela take your own destiny into your
own hands
that's called sovereignty that's what
we're all about independent free nations
with unique identities standing up for
their own interests and working with
others that's what Trump is all about
that's what Trump is actually doing here
we are taking our own destiny into our
own hands
and we're not allowing some far-off
bureaucracy to decide our future for us
and after seeing Trump's leadership on
immigration and border enforcement in
the u.s. ms merkel may be seeing a
little bit of the light herself we were
always very proud of freedom of movement
we never really thought that much about
protecting our external borders when you
look at it in hindsight we think well
how could we miss out on this how could
we never think about this we felt safe
and secure now we're working on an
entry/exit system it's no wonder in
Germany in 2016 the crime rate among
migrants and refugees skyrocketed by
more than 50% and according to the
Telegraph migrants committed nearly
175,000 suspected crimes in Germany so
suddenly president Trump's law and order
approach
the border is looking pretty good isn't
it so the elites still snipe though a
trump for his dismissal of their climate
change dogma as the French president did
today or they bristle at his decision to
renegotiate NAFTA or stand up to
cheating and intellectual property theft
by China and other nations he is
undoubtedly shaking up the world order
and reshaping the global debate in a
very positive way and though it may not
make him any friends at Davos Trump's
America first philosophy is reviving our
economy at home and it's positioning us
to lead the world from a place of
strength and it's about time and that's
the angle